so before I start let me just mention
one thing related to the last question
that we have this is I want to be a
little more precise about that I know
this whole issue of what exactly is one
showing and and let me actually
highlight also some of this somebody
interesting and quite recent counter
examples that have to do with the
following
so imagine that we have as I said before
we're just moving out the decision
question where they have a polynomial
and I want to decide where it's a samos
course or not and this is exactly the
reducible to this kind of nice and my
definite bombing question but there's
something said lying or generally can be
a little bit tricky and that's in
particular some examples and very nice
examples do to shizer well you can have
a polynomial with rational coefficients
right and I'm trying to find runoff in
the holder or decide whether this
polynomial is if someone's course or not
the geometric pictures exam is really
trying to decide the feasibility of this
amount of in problem so I'm really
trying to incite to find the
intersection of this subspace L with the
cone of posit some anything majors and
much of the difficulty he said or one of
the funny things that can happen is that
they may have learn or get of my
subspace barely touch my cone of a
particular and a single point and even
worse what can happen like in this nice
example is that even if P is rational
line of rational coefficients then they
only kill for which is true is that Q is
irrational right so somehow if I agree
so if you want to ask Amy kind of
questions about beat representation then
the question is Leno kind of okay how do
you are you even going to represent you
what does it actually mean yes it's your
bike yeah it's all about thing but I
think one has to be again careful about
it well typically one does Larry not
enough because again you don't want to
deal with this question directly
Helene says you look at the approximate
question and that's kind of a couple of
different ways of looking at it either
you think about the app know whenever I
put an epsilon in there being what can I
say about finding a Q there's really see
rows of this polynomial are very
problematic
and this is something that I know it's
not specific to sum of squares I know
there's a lot of other approaches based
on this rotation or linear planning
relaxations a lot of stuff and it's
quite typical that the running time will
depend actually on the I know kind of on
the value on one overlay know kind of
the minimum of the polynomial or run or
some function that really has to do with
how close a minimum of the polynomial in
the unit sphere and the unit circle or
roryd cap and sorry so again if you
really the only points if you want to be
really precise about it then somehow one
should care about the approximate
complexity question and in that case
we're in a kind of somehow things have
nicely behaved in terms of learning
organ of or this epsilon is but the
point is really we cannot expect no II
know kind of at least the naive
representation of a yeah yeah of Q will
work because again there are certainly
examples when Q doesn't need to be
Russian
I don't remember but essentially I think
certain leave and the ones that come
from linear programming if this is very
no can do I think party very nice I
don't remember I can give you some
reference by the way the other thing
that I should mention well you know kind
of we said this is exactly somehow they
the whenever this happens it's exactly
because things are lying are kind of
very close to being infeasible right if
you think in terms of condition number
or something like this they know that's
exactly a situation what things I mean
the polynomial having zeros my situation
got a subsidy is barely touching the
cone is exactly a situation where small
perturbations will actually change the
answer of you of the problem so somehow
it is very natural always affluence of
this type that you really want to think
in terms of condition number the size of
the Qi in terms of P right size of the
Qi you're saying some kind of sparsity
condition on Q no I don't think that
there's we know anything particularly
interesting all the sparsity of you
accept in particular situations but I'm
party said lot depends on the basis that
you pick okay so let me see what do I
want to talk about okay so we talked a
little bit about the case of a single
polynomial I want to try to understand
big piece non-negative and this is great
but you know kind of quite often we're
interested in more complicated
situations where we don't have a single
polynomial but we actually have perhaps
some kind of a set defined by polynomial
equations and recordist and my starting
point is really going to be following
imagine that somebody comes along and
gives me a set of polynomial
inequalities and I'm trying to look for
solutions over the real numbers I'm
trying to decipher the solutions and in
visual or loud or actually I'm not even
trying to decide let's imagine that for
whatever reason I convince myself that
this or I know I happen to know that
these equations
infeasible all right so these equations
have no solution there's no solution of
these equations over the real numbers my
task is somehow to try to convince
somebody else at that is the case I know
enough in its the co MP version if you
want right now you know coming here I'm
trying to prove that there's no
solutions of this equation so sorry
right so natural question that again
people have looked your way in the 60s
then in real algebraic geometry in
particular is how do you certify this
right now you can afford kind of
certificates are we're going to use to
show that these set of equations know in
organ if they don't have solutions and
there's a beautiful answer to this
essentially the real version of the new
stand set and I'll try to explain what
basis but in particular what I want to
do I mean I want to try to explain if
you want the motivation of it and while
I know it's such a beautiful and such a
lying or kind of somehow in retrospect
obvious a solution to what kind of
things would you want to do so also as I
want to emphasize right now kind of one
of the several lessons that come from
thinking about this in a more algebraic
geometric way and and I think these are
useful for some other kind of parts so
the first one the first four cups like I
was telling Ben nugget of truth but
again I want to highlight this kind of
the following but when you think about
the economic set described by equations
or even if you won't think about the
optimization problem perhaps I want to
optimize some polynomial subject to this
constraint right which is kind of like
no the epsilon more complicated version
of this then quite often we think that
the constraints have important and by
the constraints very important I mean
that the explicit form of the
constraints there is no gain no very
important they way that they're
presented right and the point only once
the lessons if you want of know you know
kind of this this more algebraic way of
thinking about this had really
constraints are kind of irrelevant the
constraints of generators for an object
and somehow what really matters is a
rather object overall and try to be very
precise our door I mean by this
and what do I mean by this I'm in the
following let's imagine that somebody
gave me an optimization problem like
this and wrote some specific set of
constraints F sub y and G sub i's and
they may have the reason to choose lane
or some constraints after buying some
specific contraint F sub I and G sub i
but the point is if I want I can look at
these constraints and I can start
generating more constraints which are
also going to be writing right if you're
like you know
so let me perhaps you concrete about it
and then I'll field also fights a little
bit more well you know kind of so what
do I mean by this imagine again that
somebody hand me this problem and rotla
is not gonna be f1 of X equal to 0 f2 of
X equal to 0 if I could that if I want
like some other constraint in there that
says three f2 is equal to c I could
that's a valid cause right or I could
write f1 of X plus five f2 of X equal to
0 and this would certainly be another
valid constraint right if I have any
solution that satisfies this it will
certainly satisfy this other conditions
above that and furthermore if I feel
even braver I can say hey why are we
multiplying with constants I can
multiply in here by some arbitrary
polynomial h1 of X I can multiply in
here by some arbitrary polynomial h2 of
X and write this constraint which is
also going to be valid and by valid I
mean that every that this is certainly
going to vanish at the feasible set so
now imagine that I don't do this but you
write all the possible constraints that
I can possibly imagine
well they're actually closed if you want
my set under the operations of taking a
constraint and multiplying it by an
arbitrary polynomial and taking linear
combinations by which I can do and I
know this will generate many many many
polynomials infinitely many and they all
want to vanish in the feasible set is
that clear and there's no reason really
why when somebody writes this these are
important these are not the important
object the in your constraint and throw
them away I mean it just exactly same
way the drain of you know somebody
scrapes a subspace and gives you a basis
then who cares about the basis we care
about the subsist well of course I'm
lying sometimes you actually want to
think about the basis particularly if
you do numerically but not today that's
only if you ever touch a computer I
think most of you are pretty safe in
that so okay good so what is the right
object in here when you think about the
most general thing that you can do
somehow it's is really taking your
constraints multiplying them by
polynomials and having them up now you
know again one of course is as a
beautiful name is exactly the ideal if
you've ever seen this that's great if
not I literally mean this which is ideal
generated by my constraints f1 to FM FM
the new condom and that means exactly
all the things that I can write as
polynomial linear combinations of my
contracts before object we understand
everything there is no other ideas these
are all equations in a quality cereal
more subtle that saw the new stuff work
again knew if we were in 1969 of enemies
which is really about playing the same
game but now with inequalities right so
I have inequality constraints G sub I of
X very : zero and I want to play a game
I'm a very sophisticated person I don't
want to think about the constraints G
sub I that you gave me I want to think
what thing do they generate and what are
the rules
what can I do if somebody gives you some
valid set of inequalities G sub I and so
generating more and more valid
inequalities G sub I that would satisfy
same problem it's kind of similar but I
have to be a little careful right just I
have to preserve the inequality
certainly what I can do is I take sums
right if G 1 and G 2 are constrained
let me forget the actually let me try
the dependence on X then g1 plus g2 is
also a valid contract right same as e 4
now
I can also multiply constraints if I
know that g1 is very early : Syria on
the official set and I know that g2 is
critical and Syria on the feasible set I
can multiply them and I'll get a ballot
constraint G 1 times G 2 which is also
going to be a valid concern I cannot do
the same thing that I was doing in here
of multiplying with an arbitrary
polynomial does that make change a sign
but I can certainly take any con so let
me get right in here product and I can
drive in here x squares I can take any
constraint GC y of X and I can multiply
it by an arbitrary square H square and
my claim is of course if G sub I is
positive on the physical set this is
going to be also non non negative on the
physical set this is also going to be
non negative on the pizza what can I do
I can take my constraints and generate
now I know again I run this machinery
forever until produce a big bag of
polynomials Sammy if you need bag of
polynomials this has a name it has two
names actually one is it either the cone
generated by the G's wise if you're
French
you call this a pre prime the pre-order
generated by the GC wise
but let me be very explicit about lino
can afford form these tanks if you
really think about taking G's of ice and
somehow doing this operation you'll see
that a generic polynomial in here the
general form of a polynomial if in here
was something of this form in here it's
a little bit more complicated so it will
look something like this it will look
essentially like a sum of squares plus
some sum of sum sum of squares times GC
y plus some sum of squares x GC y G sub
J I should be a little more precise with
editor I know plus sum of I J K of X
triple products of my constraints let me
know plus whatever and this is a finite
Samba so I only have finitely many
constraints so Dino can do at some point
is it's going to end like some sum of
course times a product of all my
constraints it's clear or should be
clear that I only need squirrel free
products in here this if at any point
you multiply why constraint by itself
you can just pull it in here with so all
my S sub alphas or sums of squares all
polynomials which are some sum squares
second they make sure that you
understand what I'm doing I'm saying
what is the set of all possible
constraints that one could possibly
write and by your possible constraints I
mean all the constraints that are easy
to write there may be constraints are
true but I could not generate it in some
kind of concise way right but learn you
know kind of this certainly everything
that writing in here is trivially
non-negative on the feasible set right
this each single term in here either
it's non-negative by construction this
is someone's course or it's a product of
things that are non-negative
you chose all these squares not
mathematically but it's easy yes exactly
so everything that I'm saying would be
true if I in here I multiply by a
positive polynomial but I don't want to
multiply by possible Long's I have no
way of certifying but that would be the
case right but if I actually write
something like this and I write an
expression of this type I can convince
you or anybody else you know this is
actually a positive polynomial on a
non-negative polynomial and mindset so
really when you talk about inequality
constraints this or maybe right in there
I will not make a choice now you know
kind of is really the object that you
should think about the specific set of
constraints that somebody wrote is an
accident it's an accident of evolution
that they decided to write those
constraints when they could have written
something different and exactly the same
things is true like in this case I mean
the way none of this should come to a
surprise of you this if you ever seen
linear programming that's exactly same
story in linear programming what we want
to do what they write when you write
Lagrange multipliers tangent constraint
line not the only difference that you
don't allow dogs will be a function of X
you are not going to be constant right
arbitrary constants but the whole idea
is that you're trying to produce
something that vanishes on the feasible
set always and in here you don't look at
this purpose you don't that you're
afraid of nonlinear stuff and we only
write in here constants times my
contract but somehow this philosophy if
you want is also really compatible with
that you do in the linear case and if I
had more time I could not just outlined
by everything fits together very nice
questions this is
so why do I you let me Demi again I mean
the philosophizing mode today so let me
just say one more thing that no kind of
this also highlights one other thing
that learner may not be too important
for what they wanted today but it's a
brilliant idea
again not mine now your good session
really if you want to try to understand
this set and this is really one of the
lessons about your geometry if you
really want to understand this set like
in here I really want to understand the
feasible set of this optimization
problem what they really want to
understand is enough functions on that
set no I know enough this actually tells
you essentially everything that you need
to know about your set and this is very
much a situation I'm really trying to
understand of the feasible set of these
equations this or if it's something and
what I'm trying to understand in here is
all the set of all functions on that yes
a real radical yeah but I'm not talking
about this today
the recent notion of the real radical so
why do I introduce this remember what I
told you what is my problem I have my
equate these equations these equations
are infeasible lying on I'm trying to
convince been that my equations are
actually in fist world and I know he
said he doesn't trust me I don't know
why but no I know kind of what he wants
is some certificate that these equations
are actually increasing world
so what certificates should I hand him
and it turns out this beautiful result
called Raynaud's the real notional sense
tells me that there's a very very
natural class of certificates for
proving invisibility of this and it's a
kind of things that noggin I think let
me write it down and we'd all agree that
line of enough somehow it's the most
natural thing that one can possibly do
because it is with water we want to do
rather water so a motivation in here I
try to write all the value inequalities
that are true on on my set all the value
equations return my set and all the
value inequalities that are true in my
set so
the fear one direction of which is
absolutely trivial and you'll see it's
really that if I succeed in finding two
polynomials F and G in such a way that
the sum of these two polynomials is a
polynomial minus 1 for F in here isn't
the ideal and G even more explicit I
want really the idea of the equations of
the F survive and I want G to be in the
cone generated by the G sub I and these
two polynomials F and G satisfy the
equation F plus G equal to minus 1 and
this is really let me write this it
really means that this polynomial is
identically minus 1 when my claim is
that this is true myself has to be empty
but this is infeasible and of course
this is a true reality it's an absolute
reality that if I succeeded in finding F
and G with these properties then should
be completely convinced that my
certainty and why do I say it's a
triviality this so perfect news exactly
is otherwise right now even if you could
take any candidate solution in here
imagine that you don't believe me you
think that this is actually feasible you
will take that X you would plug it in in
here and you will get a contradiction
right because this tells me that F has
to vanish on the feasible set this tells
me that G has to be non-negative on the
feasible set so by plugging in that that
candidate value of x that says a 0 is
equal to minus 1 and as far as I know
that
no I don't need so so you can add an
arbitrary square to G yes yeah that's in
here right yes yeah yeah
right so we all agree that you know if I
succeed in finding such an F and so DG
well you know kind of then and I call
Ben I tell them this F and G that's
actually absolutely valid certificate
that these equations are infeasible the
non-trivial part of a theorem said the
converse is true anytime that you have
learned on some arbitrary system of
equations and inequalities and I know
this is infeasible over the real numbers
then there's going to be some F and some
G in here for which this equation is
going to eat you and I will not talk too
much about the proof of the very general
case I'll just mention that again in the
combinatorial case that many of you care
about now you know this is also true
reality in the in the in the
combinatorial case this essentially this
can simulate explicit enumeration you
can just check water line or kind of add
all the points of the hypercube you know
those inequalities hold and then you
just think all that with a polynomial so
line of the existence of such a thing in
the combinatorial cases again a
triviality
so combinatorial people you're I mean in
that situation you're happy because both
directions are equally trivial
what's in non trivial part of course
that I don't want any polynomial F and G
I want F and G of low degree right or
perhaps not lower degree I want them to
be compact in some way I want to have
compact descriptions of them and that's
a difficult point well we'll see a lot
of line opportunity non-code stock they
no work in terms of trying to understand
conditions perhaps under which
certificates let's say of low degree
exist but you know if you want the
general picture is a really line of and
of as long as i interested in certifying
equations in the course of this form
there's a very very natural class of
certificates that just come from really
thinking this this right good questions
comments yes you use tuskys procedure
you get a test set
yes so one of the ways in which adi
historically this was proven first was
essentially by what's called unwinding
tarski Seidenberg so you can simulate
again
tuskie Seidenberg using polynomials and
lino the new one you can encode it this
way in fact for instance one of the
things I will not talk too much about
when people try to probe bounds on this
on the degree of these ones now you know
some of the bounds come from doing
explicitly this from tracing line of
uniform touch Asylum but rather they see
decision passive already know kind of
how trivial you can even I mean you can
even the point is for mode skin when you
multiply it by this this is already some
scores so much game itself is not a sum
of squares if you multiply it by this
then organ if you don't really get that
it is sum of squares and these kind of
things can be simulated by this so if
you didn't like or if you didn't know
that make German can equality I can just
give you this explicit expression and
you would be shocked me I should have
done that so okay let me risk it
I just wanted to yeah let me just say
and then just because I think again for
general cultural reasons now you know
kind of it's very natural to think about
this blowing organ I mean at the same
level that we think about linear form in
duality or at the same level that we
think about the complex new shell in
sense right this really right now when
you think about the equations or
equations inequalities
there's like four natural cases
depending on whether you look at
equations over an algebraically closed
field like a complex numbers or n
equations over a formerly real feels
like a real numbers and whether you look
at linear equations or you look at
polynomial equation
and somehow there's very natural classes
of certificates for all of these case
and somehow that related in very natural
ways right if you look at linear
equations over a field then line or kind
of you're solving ax equals B or trying
to probe the infeasibility of this
unlined okay now what you're really
looking is a line of kernel range type
on so if you have a system of linear
equations that it's infeasible you can
find a linear combination of the
equations that it's equal to one right I
mean that for the case of linear
equations over the reals that's exactly
LP and Farkas lemma for the case of
complex equations complex polynomial
equations the certificates that we use
to ensure that a variety something that
a set of polynomial equations doesn't
have solutions
that's exactly then your Stalin set and
again I don't have time to describe it
but it would be a great person to tell
you everything about this even in the
community real case and for the complex
case sorry for the real case for foreign
equations that's exactly what we talked
about the real nurse talent sets and I
guess the other thing that I should
mention is that all of these ones they
have kind of associated computational
tools right this is of course just
linear algebra if I want to decide of
the probe certificate of infeasibility
about linear equations or any field you
don't in your algebra if you want to
think about linear equations linear
inequalities over the reals and you do
LP and you would do simplex on interior
point methods or whatever if you look at
polynomial equations over the complex
numbers essentially you're trying to
find solutions of this equation what
you're writing here one rather than zero
finding a solution to the neutral and
set so one way of doing this close have
to what they're going to do in here if
you were to put it bound on the degree
of the ex-vice then this is just solving
a linear algebra problem if you don't
want to solve an ineligible problem you
can do Grovner basis or something like
this so like or you could complete drugs
and bases you're using using linear a
jeweler so those kind of nice
computational techniques associated to
finding certificates of infeasibility
for linear equations
and of course I guess the reason why I
am talking about this is because if I
want to again not just take this as a
given but if I actually want to find F
and G's I have to find Marino kind of
sums of squares in here and polynomials
H survive here in such a way that this
equation will be satisfied and when you
think about what is involved in it it's
really just a semi definite problem
right there's what we have to do we have
these depends are finally these are this
is a linear condition between the S
survives all these different s Y's and
the only condition that I have is that
all these polynomials they will have to
be some squares so somehow even though I
don't drive explicit and nobody should
ever write these things explicitly the
point is once you restrict the degree in
here I claim that line or kind of the
degree of this it's less than or equal
than something let me call L the level
of the hierarchy my claim is that this
is just a semi defeat problem again we
don't need to write it explicitly but
the point is I'm really finding
certificates in here of low degree and
by going up in the degree I know that
there are you know kind of eventually
solutions will exist by these three
other senses so some of these picture I
find it very useful it really allows you
to think even in other situations right
now the third thing that we should
really think about this okay how do you
even certify that solutions don't exist
and of course the love connections when
you think about what they were doing
here with proof systems right during a
what and I know yeah Jay I Jacob yeah
sorry
no he's an expert on this learning organ
on the aspect of really interpreting
these kind of things exact as a probe
system right you start with the basic
set of axioms in here and what am i
doing I'm just arriving more and more
things that are consequences of
set of axioms and I die wrong and all
these things are the things that are
conceivable that are that are sorry
concisely provable lie no from my DIYs
or and the same thing is true for they
bein the restriction in their on the
degree essentially says that none of
these other things and I can show so
that's again it follows let me not do it
beside I don't have time but essentially
if you want to show that let me tell you
the basic version but if you want to
show that a polynomial is a rebel this
seventeenth question is if P is
non-negative
is it a sum of squares of rational
functions so the version that I wrote is
I want to know whether this is empty
right or my equations is infeasible so
that's the same thing as saying that X
such that P of X is negative but
basically something right so this said
be empty in here I have strict
inequalities Street inequalities is not
quite of the form of the theorem that I
wrote in here by the way there's a more
general version of this or you allow for
in equations or the street inequalities
I mean not do this so how do you deal
with this all the algebraic geometry
trick you introduce a new variable and
you write this exactly as the equation
one ones this is 0 and P less than or
equal than 0 for y sanyo polymer but
these equations have been feasible if a
node so P cannot be zero based of this
equation so P has to be strictly
negative and if you just apply the real
nor still answer to this and you play
around no you know kind of you get
exactly a representation of the sum of
rational functions
so of course historical is an awful
thing to do now you know kind of these
only came much later and much of the
motivation was exactly this but yeah
it's an absolute no-no kind of a special
case of this very general stuff and by
the way lots and lots and lots of things
are special cases of this now you know
this is says the most general thing that
learn organ of one can again one has
really be careful about
does it mean but leia organa frail it's
hard to line all kind of understand how
to generate more and more things
Lonnegan the fat don't come from
constructions like this yes well the
thing is I mean somehow it's cheating
right if I had access to non-
polynomials no you know Gandalf then I
think you can you can essentially do
this in one shot
right this I mean yeah but I mean you're
absolutely right right I mean what the
theorem tells you is a blown organ of
you I mean you can give a constructive
so sorry easily verifiable certificate I
don't need to rely on the promise that
you tell me that some polynomially site
is non-negative right I can verify it
myself
questions so I mean really this is a
point that I want to be very very clear
now you know kind of somehow once you
look at this equation and you understand
that this is a way of certifying
learning all kind of the emptiness or
the infeasibility of equations the only
thing that you do is you say okay now I
want certificates of law degree and you
bound don't severe your stratified if
you want the set of probes in whatever
what you want if you don't like nine of
the green and you can pick in sparsity
or whatever whatever line or notion of
certification of a set that line open if
you want some way of having this
contains each other that will give you a
different hierarchy by no feel of
different ways of doing things and I
know the lots of games had one can play
so let me just at least mention also
again for general culture like a
different different variations or even
special cases that learn all kind of
some how one looks all the time is when
you start assuming more and more or you
assume perhaps different properties
about your F survives on G sub i's now
perhaps you can simplify or knock and of
a change if you want the structure of
things in here so let me talk about
perhaps rather than non negativity sorry
rather than emptiness let me talk about
the question of line
to certify that piece positive on some
set right and again let me just pick the
inequalities I don't care about the
equations all I want I just want to
contrast or comparison away a few things
that one can possibly do so in our
geometry there's different kinds of or
real are your joint your different kinds
of certificates that one can think about
again depending on what you what you're
willing to assume on the GI s-- so one
notion is kind of lined up this fall if
you want which is really again line I
think it's the most general thing that
one could possibly do
but then for instance people have looked
at particular cases and Handelman for
instance look at representations and
again I made me some of the assumptions
and whatever work for instance you look
at your polynomials being linear so
essentially this corresponds to the case
of a polynomial non-negative on a
polytope right and in that case one can
give what's called representation
theorem some it'll let me write perhaps
a general form in here all the theorems
are of the form if you have a polynomial
actually unfold all of those you need
streak positivity on that set for
exactly same reasons that we talked
about before
now you know if you insist on
inequalities then you will not have
certificates of this type although those
kind of things will work so this kind of
things will work what for instance
you may want to represent P in some
particular form so let me make it
precise so for instance in the
particular case were this hundred man
representations are whenever Jesus by
constraints of median so real it's a
polynomial strictly positive on the
polytope so what Handelman says are in
that case P has a representation of the
form let me actually perhaps Rayleigh
explicitly that were all DSO buys are
constants
so whenever you look at positivity of a
polynomial Street positivity of a
polynomial on a polytope then it's
enough to pick all the s wise to be
concerned so this gives some linear
programming hierarchy you know kind of
shotgun but some other kind of results
were for instance what you require yes
yes
wait cross terms okay yeah yeah so the
only thing for yeah peace not compacts
right my polynomial is not come back you
still need the products but you don't
have no in okay no in that case and
again there's typically some maybe let
me be a bit more precise in here no you
know plus compactness
so Morgan has another beautiful theorem
that says what happens in the lemak only
said s 1 s is compact and in that case
you don't need the problem sorry no smog
inserted in the compact case then this
is fine now you know kind of Street
positivity is kind of enough for a
representation of this type so it says a
P itself we have a representation of
this type let me know kind of been put
in our has a novel version which is
essentially the one that was used by
Lucerne
that says that if s is let me write
algebraically compact which it means and
this is very interesting so it means not
only it's compact but I need to have
some algebraic way of checking that the
service compact right so what that means
that not only line ok so if you can come
with your set and tell myself is compact
but you have to provide an algebraic
certificate of compartments so for
instance by showing that there's some
linear combination of your equations or
Pournami linear combination of the
equations that line ok that gives you a
unique ball or something like this in
which case what happens is that you
don't need the products
so you don't need the products of the
constraints so what's good about these
kind of things are you know the more
structure you put on this one's right
now kind of the different line of their
different ways in which you can play
yourself one thing that again we have to
be careful with this kind of results is
that none of these results they tell you
anything about trade-offs in terms of
the degree it may happen that learning
okay you don't need the products but now
you need much long much higher degrees
in your xxx vision in fact that is not I
mean small - Morgan has a paper line of
a no showing exactly misrepresentations
without products I know can be worse at
least in certain cases no you know and
so somehow there's somehow general
trade-offs between the I know kind of
somehow the how generate your
certificate sell versus what you assume
on the degrees but you know I think
what's really important in here is not
the form of line or kind of you use
these of that but really somehow now you
know what these things are doing and the
only ended up doing is you try to
generate as many constraints as you can
and then you try to find the
contradiction and all of these can be
completely automated this underneath
your just solving some a different
problems so this version I mean
depending on how explicit you want to do
is either Caribbean or single certainly
miss tangle wrote it very explicit in
exactly this form well you know kind of
some algebraic geometers claim that this
is essentially all the in cribbens paper
right okay no and of course it yep sorry
oh so in here if you want in here I'm
talking about in feasibility so this may
require when you apply it you know in
this case you take your polynomial and
multiply your polynomial by something
else along the lines of what they've
done so you would show for instance at
one plus that 1 plus is sum of squares
times Q times P has this form which is a
more general certificated than taking
this equal to 0 and again there's
examples for you but you gain a lot by
doing this so there's many parameters
yeah questions before I move on I won't
be moving on too much so one of the
things that kind of somewhat frustrating
and here is that it's not the release to
understand why these things are true no
no no one again in the in the general
case if you don't really know anything
about your polynomials you so why learn
okay no then the point is very
complicated things can happen right it's
very much like you know in like you know
when you look at the new Stevenson's
right I mean the big rebounds for
instance sometimes are very large and
they're very large not for geometric
reasons somehow because but the largest
polynomials can do fine you can encode
funny stuff inside the points and I
think about multiplicities I know you
can essentially look at polynomials at
line open for the geometry is not
apparent from the from the equations but
one thing that not at least I want to
highlight is it it's kind of otherwise
somewhat mysterious as you end up with
this kind of things is why like I said
earlier in the hypercube case in the
particular case when you look at the
polynomial on the vertices of the
hypercube what is kind of statement is
trivial right line of why somehow it's
very easy to certify that if my
polynomial is indeed non-negative in the
hypercube then I can write very
explicitly some what's called
certificate data case written against a
trivial idea but I know enough to some
extent the proof of the general case at
least in certain situations is not much
more difficult
think about instead of a hypercube think
about the compact situation and line or
certainly the same kind of thing will be
true so why is this even true or what am
I trying to show I'm trying to show that
if P is non-negative on the hypercube on
the vertices of the hypercube there's
some nice a mosque or certificate that
certifies this and it is kind of very
very simple right so let me define so
think about the hypercube in here so I
have a function that they find somehow
in the vertices of my hypercube in there
let me try to understand this function
first I give out the function the
function that see
everywhere but it's one at a particular
point right so let me write the
explicitly so for instance if this point
let me write in the in the easiest form
first let me imagine that this point my
preferred point is the old ones vector
right there of course you can write it
very explicitly so what is this function
is 1 plus X 1 divided by 2 1 plus xn
divided by 2 right so I claim that the
Delta function is exactly right now kind
of this function which is kind of easy
right if any X of I is minus 1 and this
vanishes plane of X or DX of Y star
equal to 1 this gives you the value 1
all right so this of course only works
at this point but of course I can do
this have any other point right now by
doing some kind of linear transformation
if I wrote the function explicitly if
this vertex is a vertex B then the only
thing that change changes I think I have
to do something like this the one simple
exercise to check this function P V of X
takes a value of 0 at every vertex
except that the vertex be more or less
clear like the same argument I was
saying before right if all the V
survives will be survive yeah what we
say vertex of the guy thank you plus
minus 1 plus minus 1
I want one plus bi is that true
suddenly when it's one it works when
it's minus it changes a sign I mean okay
some version of this I just want to
ensure that I get a one in here and not
a minus one so whatever version it is
now it's something like this so why do I
do this stupid thing the point is if I
have the Delta function then the inside
the square of the Delta function is that
the function remains a different way
Delta function is a squatter so what
this tells me is that I can write any
function P of X as a sum of P of Y Delta
Y of X square
it clear why this is the case because
this is the same thing perhaps I should
have written this earlier I know some of
P of why I should let me do it that way
so you don't get super confused let me
first claim that this is true right
which is clearly true because I know
this is zero at every point except when
y is equal to X so I get the same thing
and like I said before the Delta
function when I square it I get the same
thing
so what this gives is an explicit
representation of my function as a sum
of course and these coefficients are
fine they are non-negative less my
polynomial is non-negative so in the
discrete case
the factor is non-negative polynomial
system of course is absolute triviality
is this in the compact case it's not
much more difficult there's really the
only thing that you have to do is you
have to you have to show that you can
approximate a delta function with
polynomials but again I'm essentially
the same thing is kind of choked and of
course implicit may be sold away and by
non-porous paper so you know the end of
it all these papers learn or somehow
what you know unwind what's actually
going on is really some kind of argument
of this type but when you look at these
hierarchies what the end up doing in the
limit is just evaluating the polynomial
out all the possible points and that's
why when you let the degrees go to
infinity essentially you recover
completeness again the general case is
more complicated there's reasons why
learning somehow the non geometric
situation is more complicated but that's
right
no and I'll talk about this of course
the same thing as in here the whole game
is under there's two aspects of it right
the whole game is a depending on what
you want to do you never care about the
converse statement because once you
succeed in finding line you know kind of
the solution of the ACP whatever this is
proving the bound that you want if you
want to prove theorems learning organ of
then of course you want to have much
finer control of what the degree of
these polynomials are depending on the
structure of your polynomial
go to gain insight from this Delta
function expansion so clearly it cruises
or your comment is fine is there any way
to see from this such an expansion why
their ever behold or what we need in
order to get a very low degree so so the
question is can you actually use this
learning or somehow to produce bounds on
the approximation quality as if you can
now I know by understanding how well
that the functions can approximate so
you have well polynomials can
approximate it as a function you do get
bounce they know the product but a
feature of that approach if you think
about the labeling here so we induce any
property whatsoever of people so in that
case and you get results about
approximation like for arbitrary
polynomials and the point is that
they're you know dogs tend to be
learning organising sample Wars done
learn all kind of all the situations
like Mac Scott or really interesting
situations what do you put additional
structure on on the parlament uses a
special specter of the queue doesn't it
because it's a truly important real line
and I tell you values the degree has be
to the end in general yeah somehow the
degree is not really the right measure
or or let me say this way on the
hypercube linear degrees really bad
right I mean saying in the hyper Qi hub
port number of the VM is really bad on
the line now you know somehow saying I
have a partner of degree N is not bad so
I think it has more to do not with this
argument but Larry no more to do with
what is polynomial time or not
polynomial time in that case telling on
we both just said the dimension of the
space of polynomials of degree to the N
in one variable is to the N yeah and
truce yeah like this song essentially
two to the n yes they saw moment choose
the you
here always particularly what matters is
to match the dimension of the dimension
of that spectrum space right even though
you can do it with poor numbers of the
VN what you've rightly semi-definite
program if you do it that way of I mean
you need to parameterize all the
polynomials of degree up to and that's
essentially this exponential okay good
so let me say let me say two things I
know and I want somehow point out let me
point out very explicitly to the kind of
things that I think uncle will talk
about in much more detail which is
exactly the question of line know-how
for particular problems how do we
control the degree of this certificate
right whenever I look at either Brandon
problems or problems of a particular
type how do I get bounds on the degree
of the certificate right line or kind of
and this is a very interesting question
the other thing I want to talk about
this somehow only some obscure stuff is
a very general machinery right now they
said there were no assumptions at all
about what line or kind of this
polynomial self and G's plane over
somehow and again some of you have seen
this picture like this very general
machinery or somehow line of enough you
start with your polynomials or
polynomial constraints you go to the SOS
cloud line okay the one in the end now
you know kind of what you get is some
kind of big semi defeat problem in there
that you have to solve in some kind of
way and there's many many questions I
guess that one can ask or line of many
research questions if you want that no
nope you know I think that one needs to
build with I mean of course one would
lie to have semi definite promise at all
small one would like to have the line of
algorithms for solving this and I
haven't at all talked about algorithms
for doing this I think uncle will
mention a little bit and of course will
here and leave it more I think later
when the one-ders
talks about interior point methods for
distance for solving dissing a different
problems but also a big part of I think
what I want me to do and what we do is
really trying to understand in here what
are the best
semi definite problems that you can
write
and by this I'm in the following for
most problems that we care about these
polynomials of no the arbitrary there's
a lot of structure in the polynomials at
one organ the fat they come now you know
whatever you're faced with any
particular problem and the question is
to what extent you can write better than
my definite problems in order to do this
so let me understand inks for doing this
and the reason why I want to mention
this is a connect to it to a number of
things that line organ uh we'll see in a
more or less explicit way I think later
so one has to do and I guess we've seen
a little bit of this before now you know
kind of in the case where I have
explicit equations right so in my
notation that I use in here is when I
have equations F sub I of X equal to
zero think about in this case if I work
on the hypercube I'll have Dino kind of
this equations XY square of -1 equal to
0 so in that case even when you think
about the problem of deciding if a
polynomial is a semo's course or not
somehow the general machinery that I
talked about in here maybe they know
kind of some Hollywood suboptimal in the
following sense
think about the case that I have a
polynomial and I really only care about
this polynomial in the hypercube then
one of the things that I think many of
you are familiar with is that really
don't want to think if I'm really if I'm
interested in the programming the
hypercube I can always think that P is a
multi linear polynomial right I can be
essentially on the hypercube the square
of any monomial is going to be equal to
the monument itself I know X Y square is
equal to X Y well it depends on let me
do the seed of one hypercube just so
it's so so in that case right now if we
look at squirrel free
monomials and in that case for instance
indexing now in a kind of my sum of
squares matrix by all the monomials of
degree less than or equal then something
doesn't make sense what I really want to
do is somehow index only by the multi
linear monomials and similarly when I
expand this equation I write this is
equal to this I don't want to literally
check that they're the same I want to
check that they reduce to the same thing
under this more tailing amount right
they just agree on the variance of the
hypercube so what's the general version
of this essentially if I have equations
in here what I want to work is not on
the polynomial ring but I want to work
on this quotient aspects I want to move
out but the ideal and if I have a nice
way of working on this quotient drink
like if I have a global basis or
something then that's a much nicer way
of writing this kind of sum of squares
that makes the other case which again I
will not talk too much I just won't say
anything
it's a case of sparsity right so perhaps
your polynomial your input podium and
think about now the case of justice
siding if a poor nominee sparse
then perhaps my pollyana is very sparse
line up atoms there's a better way of
doing the sum of squared stuff and
actually there is learning okay now if
your polynomial esports and by one has
to be very careful about what do we mean
by sports there's both a naive notion of
sports of having few coefficients does
their job algebraic geometric notion of
being sparse that means that the newton
polytope is smart there's something
called the Newton pollito but if that
polytope is small then that will mean
the department's faster so these we more
or less understand very interesting
question that we don't know actually
hopefully some of you would be
interested in this what happens in the
black box case but i have perhaps a
polynomial given in some kind of black
box way now in perhaps a gray box if you
want you know perhaps or some structure
in there you know can we do any of these
stuff in some kind of clever way Adam
symmetries is kind of a very interesting
situation so symmetries is the case or
you have sample you know again let me
think about the case of a single
polynomial P like before and P may be
invariant under the action of a group so
perhaps have some group of
transformations and P happens to be
invariant under the scope action
simplest case think about peering in
violent and there permuting all the
variables simple case so it turns out
there's a very nice theory that one can
do in this case what you don't really
need to work somehow on the base doing
some scores on the big Parliament ring
but you can work on what's called the
invariant ring and there are some very
nice representation theoretic tools now
you know somehow to understanding how do
you work in this case
and now you know enough there are some
very interesting and recent developments
I love this stuff now in organ of some
connections right now between this
symmetry reduction approach and
something called flag address that was
borrowing to introduce a while ago so
the connections with symmetries is like
this very nice paper right like they
liked a lot by Raymond sing Saunderson
Enrique Thomas it's somehow connect this
idea of flag algebras with symmetry
reduction and the way I like to describe
is these guys would kill me knowing okay
no he said really doing some of sports
in Assam Tapia like this idea is that
line of enough you don't want to do sum
of squares with finitely many variables
like one dozen here but you actually
want to work directly in the limit what
you have Lionel kind of an infinite
number of horribles and there's a very
formal way I mean of somehow either
taking this limiting process which is
what they do or somehow what for a
smaller ball so England you're working
directly in innocent opium now you know
again no one somehow there's a very nice
connection between these kind of things
so the point again I don't expect you
know not enough to get this the point I
really want to make is that there's a
lot of somehow once you take these very
basic constructions and then you are
structure you say okay I'm not really
looking at arbitrary polynomials generic
polynomials my parents are very special
you start recovering lots of things that
don't look at all like line or kind of
the standard stop right no he no one and
this is a thing a very interesting
process I think it will be very
interesting or at least very interesting
to understand all other limits of this
kind of machinery
I think uncle will talk a lot about
again in particular this question of how
do we get better how do we understand
against the behavior of these
relaxations like no either for random
problems or for concrete problems and
the other thing which I didn't mention
anything at all and he'll talk about
much more explicitly is what it's a dual
picture they know what happens on the
dual side every semi definite problem
that you'll ever meet cancel it do one
so something that's perhaps not obvious
is line
is a dual picture in here and the other
thing that's very intrinsic and will
connect with the kind of things that
Michelle was talking about is how do we
take these dual solutions and drown them
in some way how do we even think about
this under some very beautiful machinery
that not a whole bunch of people
including many of the audience have been
working in in in terms of laying of how
do we take these solutions and produce
actual primary solution from this
[Applause]
if you expand the set of coefficients
from squares and add like wall these
inequalities they give from America I
[Music]
mean so certainly you cannot let me talk
about the giant pigeon just in a second
you can suddenly had anybody make
quantities so if lining up for whatever
reason I happen to know that they're in
a kind of there's some family of
polynomials which are non-negative like
now you know a Motzkin I can very easily
throw in in there plus coefficients and
Motzkin so that's the thing now you know
kind of I don't know any I mean a thing
for instance what what one does in all
this line of some of non negative
circuits polynomials or ruling of the
you essentially pick X positive pattern
and you only play with the coefficients
so essentially you pick certain
coefficients essentially a simplex in
the Newton polytope is the simplex then
you pick an additional point and then
you write geometric programs that will
describe inequalities between these n
plus 1 coefficients and line or somehow
you throw this it it would be very very
nice if there was a way of somehow
spinning this under the natural group
action right larionova nothing it's not
just about darling you find out on the
case of munchkin right I don't want to
add more skin in three variables I want
to add all the mod skins that result
from playing in learning again have any
possible values of x times x and y think
about lion org and I guess in axioms
terms I want to add the template I don't
want to add line you know kind of the
axiom and as far as I know we don't know
how to do this
there are any complexity advantage of
the certificate over the decision
procedure
I think the miracle in here if you want
is that not only the certificates exist
but learn all kind of some how we can
actually find them efficiently by
solving the semi-different problems yeah
somehow there doesn't seem to be any
advantage in this case learn all kind of
and let me perhaps also be just a little
bit precise I don't want when I claim
the Nagano Fed will write this now you
know kind of equal to minus one and I
make all these statements about the
degree of the F sub i's which is to
apply them in water every time that I
talk about the degree of these
polynomials I really mean the syntactic
degree right you know kind of so I don't
I'm not a Buddhist for instance the
degree of this polynomial is actually
zero right the degree of this whole
thing this is exactly equal to the
polynomial minus one so the degree the
true degree is zero there's lots of
cancellations that happen so I'm really
when I talk about degree I mean the
syntactically the degree that you will
obtain if you just look at this
expression you ignore the fact that
cancellations may happen in the fully
general case if you don't put any
assumptions whatsoever they're awful and
by awful I mean yeah like they're super
exponential whatever whatever none of
that happens in the concrete case were
somehow the reset and you can act and
you have access to that set but it's
very different from the situation more
line I just hand you some equations you
have no idea whether it is feasible or
not you have no idea how the
infeasibility of this is encoded the
same thing that happens in the notional
sets that learn how you can write this
telescopic equations you know kind of
that word you don't know I mean there's
funny games that one can play with
polynomials let me say that this way so
the bounds are actually pretty bad I
mean the
non bounce in the degree that in the
fully general situation that pretty bad
none of this happens learning organ of
like in this kind of concrete situation
so you have it set and I know kinda man
you have access and you know that
somehow that set has an interior and
it's not line okay not a mysterious
thing yeah I can be more precise of line
but the point is a dryer if you just see
equations it's very difficult to reason
about line no kind of weather line of
these equations are they define a set or
they don't
I think Pablo
[Applause]